herzlich willkommen zur leute ich bin
heute wieder für euch am start mit einer
neuen hilft mir folge leute für alle die
letzten beiden folgen auf einem kanal
gesehen haben keine sorge ganz so
schlimm wird's heute nicht es wird er es
wird er wieder bisschen mehr angenehm
unterhalt haben sind einige von euch hat
sich gewünscht dass ich mir mal die
hierfür folge mit dem genialen titel und
inhalt ich liebe meinen lehrer aber eher
meine mutter mal reinziehen und deutlich
zu sagen warum kein großes drumherum was
die ganz normale alltagssituationen was
macht man wenn alle frauen im haushalt
auf einen mann stehen und dieser eine
mann ist der lehrer der tochter sollte
das eine situation wo wir alle ratschlag
brauchen und wie dieser ratschlag
aussieht sind wir jetzt
[Musik]
ich habe ja sehen wir ganz klassische
schule in deutschland wie wir wissen ist
die durchschnittliche klassengröße in
deutschland wie hoch zwei deswegen sie
mir genau alltagssituation drin
zwei schüler auf einen lehrer so ist das
ganze mal in deutschland sieht so aus
als hätte jemand so versucht irgendwie
so auf unterricht zu tun wie im
unterricht war dann einfach johann
wolfgang von goethe mit geburts und
todesdatum an die tafel geschrieben so
sieht nicht unterricht aus und zwar weil
ich wissen dann sagt es dann als
powerpoint oder lieber als plakat machen
praktisch ganz gut das hältst du von von
powerpoint jetzt wird's haben leute die
vor ort und kann man da schon mal geben
dieses junge mädchen dass wir gerade
ihren stift gedroppt hat die heißt
scheinbar ariana ich glaube dass ariana
die eine affäre mit ihrem rad sie hat
natürlich das schiff an dieser stelle
gejoggt und danach ihren gesäß zu
präsentieren wenn ich das jetzt mal so
fair ausdrücken darf und da haben leute
es sind alltägliche situationen
deutschen klassenräumen zwei
schülerinnen eingestellten inhaltliche
frage die andere mutiert so stripperin
ich habe gedacht das kann ja sein dass
die technik das plakat mache weil dann
hab ich gedacht kann ich auch noch die
bilder von goethes frauen einfügen es
kommt überhaupt nicht lang also diesen
blick gesehen
das sah nicht so aus wie jemand der
gerade irgendwas sieht was eine
irgendwie spaß macht oder was ihm
gefällt das so aus wie das gesicht von
jemandem der morgens in die dusche
steigt halb im schlaf noch und stadt
statt warm einfach auf komplett kalt
stellt ich muss noch mal mein
taschengeld verdienen du weißt ja ich
arbeite ja sagt man in so einem
etablissement das mit dem ja also das
hat diese stangen wie die feuerwehr aber
da geht es nicht ums feuer löschen oder
was macht dieser lehrer vegas sein
einziges argument ist so ja ich meine
das könnte zu jemand sehen also
ansonsten finde ich das als erwachsener
mensch der wahrscheinlich 35 ist
vollkommen unverbindlich was mit einer
minderjährigen so ist es in der story
schülerin anzufangen
gar kein problem das einzige was mich
stört ist dass uns jemand sehen kann
ok alles klar ariana wo steckst du sagst
gemeinte muss ich komme mir jetzt ich
muss nur nummern im wichernstift noch
zusammen ja ich musste meine bücher
zusammenraufen
mal ganz davon abgesehen dass man das
was was hat das verb laufen in diesem
kontext zu suchen deine bücher dann die
stifter meine verehrte kollegin arianna
fliegen auf seinem platz saß gerade eben
auf dem lehrerpult für den fehler
so hast du den gesehen wieder schon
lächelt aber da ist viel zu alt ist ja
nicht das richtige mann zum küssen sehr
gute argumentationsketten malaria
gespart wo es kaum zu eigentlich ja hör
einfach auf uns okay ja aber er kannte
und julius business one und es ist so
gut läuft kann ich verstehen aber
trotzdem also bitte denkt daran was okay
man kennt diese situation wenn man
einfach 17 ist und ein mann will ist
klar ist klar so schwester ich weiß dann
aber du bist leider erst du bist zwar
erst vor fünf jahren in die pubertät
gekommen so aber schon okay vollkommen
okay das jetzt in man willst der 35 ist
es mit sicherheit das richtige für dich
[Gelächter]
was war das doch gerade fake lache 3000
alter wenn man fake lachen leveln könnte
dann wäre das level 3000 und danach
leute wirklich klassiker trifft man die
eigene mutter warum weil sie in der
fußgängerzone in köln an einem baum
steht
es ist das was mütter üblicherweise
mache in deutschland sich in
fußgängerzonen an bäumen aufhalten
ich weiß was mir heute passiert ist ein
klassenzimmer da war ich diese serie so
ein broker
anstatt dass man zumindest über versucht
man ist ja eine fernsehproduktion heute
das ist eine fernsehproduktion die
wahrscheinlich schon mindestens hundert
tausende bis millionen menschen im
fernsehen sehen anstatt dass man
versucht irgendwie in box studio oder so
zu mieten irgendwas nein da wird eiskalt
im wohnzimmer gedreht so wird es
aussieht ist der box hat mich mal in der
decke befestigt sondern er hätte ihn
einfach und der typ da rechts macht
sport in la cargohose und das hat diese
schülerinnen diese ariana wahnsinns
na ja auf jeden fall als die andere
schülerin raus war unglaublich heute
unglaublich es einfach es muss einfach
sagen das passt wirklich wieder alles
bei dieser serie es ist einfach alles
von hoher qualität auch die art und
weise wie er diesen boxer kaut das sind
sicher dass sie zertrümmern die schläge
der mike tyson ist nichts da ging ich
visualisiert ist jetzt mal so gut ich
das kann mal aufregt dass das nicht geht
ich habe gesagt ich will das nicht
aber dann haben wir um geknutscht was
ihr habt rumgeknutscht ja also zuerst
hab ich dir hab ich dir kurz gesagt dass
es nicht geht
das habe ich dann so ja also hält im
rahmen einer möglichkeit gemacht und ich
bin drei sekunden lang gesagt dass wir
das jetzt nicht machen können und dass
ich falls ich das mache mit ihr mein
komplette karriere riskieren und dann
nach diesen drei sekunden habe ich jetzt
einfach gemacht ein genie der julius das
aber erst der knaller
da kam doch die freundlich noch einmal
die tür rein und ich bin mir sicher dass
die uns gesehen hat es kommt mir
natürlich so sein leben liegt gerade in
trümmern vor ihm verliert seinen job und
ist so das war ja ganz schön nerven die
hat uns auf jeden fall gesehen so also
wir haben andere personen die beweisen
können dass wir eine lehrer schüler
beziehung haben und die auch diese
beweise beim rektor vorbringen werden
also ich bin jetzt bald arbeitslos
[Musik]
länger gebraucht
warum ist jetzt überrascht dass ihre
mutter am baum chip wir hatten doch
gerade eben fest gehabt ticker das regt
mich auf
ariana wir haben gerade eben
festgehalten du solltest du dich auch
wissen in welchem land lebst du den
lambo gestern ein mütter in deutschland
zählen in fußgängerzonen an bäumen da
halten sie sich meistens auf deswegen
tun
mama hat nämlich seit kurzem einen neuen
lover aber ich muss sagen es hat sich ja
ja ja denkt sich so bruder was geht da
ab weil denke ich mir jetzt auch
haltiger was geht denn hier ab
okay gut was machen wir das heute haben
geben auf tour ich habe heute hat keiner
zeit so pilgerreise park am geländer ist
doch kein sport alter guck dir mal den
typen an
kein einziger schweißtropfen den kann
man ja seht ihr auf diesen boxsack steht
sc sports drauf ok sports das steht
dafür dass das sportartikel sind die zum
betreiben von sport geeignet sind das
heißt man strengt sich an
man schwitzt und nicht man streichelt
den sack mit zwei schlägen pro minute
du solltest ja auch mal so viel spaß ein
bisschen locker werden muss um einen
spanischen zufrieden also so wie es
läuft kann es nicht besser
folgendes boxen kann nicht besser werden
es kann nicht besser werden was soll er
machen heute also jede jedes prozent was
er noch da an schlagkraft mehr rein legt
in diesem boxsack wird den sack
zerfetzen und wird seinen
trainingspartner ins krankenhaus
schicken
es kann nicht besser werden in seinem
leben nichts auch nicht die die hosen
auswahl beim sport das ist schon das
optimum
oh gott mein gott ich hatte ganz kurz
den titel vergessen heute
ich hatte den titel vergessen jetzt
jetzt fällt mir wieder ein was er gerade
im heute er hat eben diese legitim
darüber geredet das hat auch ein anderes
state hat und jetzt sehe ich diese frau
von hinten dem moment mal
dies ein bisschen alt ja leute es ist
die mutter nein alarmstufe rot
heute habe ich übrigens erspart jetzt an
der stelle noch dicker das ist ja
wirklich so harald f was da in dieser
szene in den nl
das war nicht mal wieder ein sehr
begabter völlig weitergesucht leute es
gibt leider in dieser folge kein
showdown wo der typ irgendwie mit der
taste gange ist und dann die mutter rein
kommt aber so gibt es nicht das hat uns
etwa 2 in diesem fall nicht gegönnt ich
glaube das finde ich sogar besser als
einzige was er macht es erholt sich bei
der familie bei ihr zu hause mit der
tochter noch schön 63 und torpediert
damit komplett seine jobaussichten für
die nächsten paar jahre also muss wieder
sagen leute kompletter drecks folge aber
sehr gut geeignet zum forschen hat mir
richtig spaß gemacht heute zu drehen
wenn euch auch dann will ich mich freuen
wenn ihr die banken haben kein foul
kleines video abchecken ich werde daraus
heute bleibt stabil und nicht auf